en bogotá como en el resto de américa
latina' las plazas de mercados son
pequeños universos sociales y culturales
en pandemia a muchos comerciantes se ven
obligados a acudir acompañados de sus
hijos que terminan por ser parte del
lugar en este contexto nace el programa
nidos arte en primera infancia una
iniciativa del distrito de bogotá que
busca que niños y niñas de hasta 5 años
para los que los mercados son un segundo
hogar puedan conectar con el arte y
hacer volar su imaginación en un espacio
de tanto estímulo como es una plaza de
mercado para mí así es vital poder
garantizar los derechos culturales de
los más y niñas en cualquier lugar que
se encuentre entonces podemos
desarrollar alguna alianza con inditex
para poder llegar a los niños y las
niñas de primera infancia que están en
las plazas de mercado acompañando a sus
papás a trabajar bogotá tiene 44 plazas
de mercado entre públicas y privadas la
primera experiencia ha contado con la
participación de 25 familias en estos
encuentros han podido ver y participar
en obras de teatro
además de pintar moldear plastilinas y
experimentar con las frutas de la plaza
una iniciativa que desde el distrito de
bogotá esperan ampliar en el futuro pero
queremos poder llegar a más plazas para
garantizar a los niños espacios
adecuados para que puedan disfrutar
obras escénicas y musicales pensadas
especialmente para ellos y para
garantizar sus derechos en cualquier
lugar unos derechos que unidos busca que
vayan más allá del espacio educativo o
familiar y convertir así a la ciudad y
sus puntos de encuentro social como las
plazas de mercado en un elemento
educador y de integración social más
poniendo a la comunidad y sus niños en
el centro